the church is really trying to sweep
this under the rug and
you know we're pretending we're all
united we're the united methodist church
after all
you know and we don't really have an
issue with this and i think what
happened
during my trial and after my trial in
the aftermath of it people
really saw how many are in support of
the lgbt community and
lgbt rights if the church abandons its
teaching on sexuality
there will in fact be a more a much
deeper division
and a formal schism
how do voluntary private organizations
change
or refuse to change policies that are
central to their missions that's the
underlying issue that many religious
groups are facing when it comes to gay
marriage
religious practices change all the time
just ask catholics who celebrated mass
in latin until the 1950s or protestant
groups that started ordaining women as
ministers in the 1970s
but are there certain core beliefs that
can never change
this is a story about how one church the
united methodist
is negotiating a difference of opinion
that could split the church
the practice of homosexuality
is incompatible with christian teaching
we cannot perform a wedding
for you and your loved one in our church
that's the message my son had heard
and that drove him into depression and
to the brink of
suicide and when my son asked me six or
now
seven years ago dad
will you do the wedding for me there was
no
way in hell that i would have said no to
my son
frank schaefer is a former united
methodist pastor
he was stripped of his credentials last
december after a church trial
found him guilty of disobeying the
church law when he performed his
own son's gay wedding in 2007.
united methodist book of discipline
which contains methodist laws and
doctrine
strictly forbids the celebration of
same-sex unions
i came to the conclusion i said okay
well
if this means that i'm going to be fired
then so be it
you know but i i will perform this
wedding for my son
i saw it as an act of love you know and
and furthermore i mean
just consider this if i had said no to
him
it would have negated all of those
affirmations my wife and i had given him
you know from day one when he came out
you know when we said to him things like
you know you are
created in the image of god just like
everybody else you know god created you
the way you are gay and all three out of
four of frank's children are gay
before officiating the wedding frank
informed his supervisors of his decision
he did not however inform his
congregation six years after the wedding
a member of frank's congregation in
lebanon pennsylvania
learned of the wedding and filed a
complaint a 13-member jury of pastors
found him guilty
of disobeying methodist rules i lost my
credentials i
was immediately terminated from my
position i lost all my privileges
i no longer have a guaranteed
appointment i lost my tenure
and the status of of being a reverend it
was a very
painful experience i guess at that
moment i i realized how
how much of a calling it is for me to to
be a pastor that's who i am that's
what i've done for the last 20 plus
years frank is using this opportunity to
speak out against what he believes is
discrimination within the methodist
church
and he's not alone the issue is deeply
divided the nation's largest mainline
protestant denomination
it's important to remember the ultimate
debate is not over sexuality that's just
one
sort of battle flag issue in the current
culture wars the debate that's been
going on for the last 150 years
within western christianity is between
traditionalist and
more liberal tradition revisionist mark
thule president of the institute on
religion and democracy
a conservative think tank in washington
d.c says frank's defrocking
was justified any kind of a church law
by definition has to be upheld otherwise
it's not a church law thule says the
liberal side of the church
is trying to assert its loose
interpretation of biblical scriptures on
the church as a whole
i think the problem with the protestant
liberal revisionism
is that it empowers or privileges the
current generation of elites and it
asserts a superiority of intellect and
spirituality over everybody else in the
world
currently and throughout history the
issue of homosexuality has been hotly
debated within the methodist church
since 1972 when language
condemning the practice was first
introduced into the book of discipline
the methodist general conference meets
every four years and
each time has voted to uphold the
prohibition on same-sex unions
liberal theologians are a sizable
minority within the church and have been
pushing back against the restrictive
language
every step of the way hundreds of
methodist ministers have publicly
rejected the doctrine and
like frank some face punishment by trial
for performing same-sex weddings
frank says he doesn't want to add any
language to the book of discipline
mandating acceptance of same-sex unions
he just wants to take out the words
condemning it
by just taking that language out we're
just leaving it up to everybody
individually if if if there are pastors
that are uncomfortable
in leading gay marriages they don't have
to do it
but those who are comfortable and feel
called to do it
they are allowed to without facing
trials well that's merely the current
talking point of the liberal side of the
church we just want to create an open
tent for both sides
but we i think both sides understand
though that
in fact that would just be one step
towards deconstructing the church's
traditional point of view
and ultimately in very quick time
ratifying and affirming
the liberal revisionist point of view
fellow mainline protestants have
already moved towards accepting gay
unions this includes the united church
of christ
and the episcopal church of america but
the methodist church
seems to be going in the opposite
direction the margin of vote against
changing the church's stance on
homosexual unions
was 61 to 39 at the 2012 general
conference which was a wider disparity
than in 2008.
the explanation has to do with the
structure of the methodist church
the united methodist church is very
centralized the general conference makes
rules for everything by way of a
majority vote
this is very different from other
mainline denominations who operate as a
loose federation of congregations with a
shared tradition
but not necessarily the same rules this
loose federation
allows the different congregations
across the world more autonomy
congregations in the united methodist
church have less autonomy and a
significant portion of the church lies
outside of the united states while
membership in the united states is
declining
overseas branches are increasing and
these tend to be more conservative
methodism has a global membership it's
not us only
like the other old line denominations
and so the growing african church has
provided the numbers
to block the acceptance of their agenda
on the sexuality issue
advocates of gay marriage say that the
best hope for the united methodist to
stay united
is to allow local congregations around
the world more autonomy
without that they say the church could
face a formal schism
but sometimes a division has to happen
so that you know both parts of the
church
can minister with integrity
and certainly that's not happening right
now we're saying with the united
methodist church but we're not
you know it's a fake union it's it's not
real
and it compromises ministers and
people's integrity
you